On m'a banni, mais je reviendrai à Paris
Petite Cosette ! Je te sauverai !
*Cosette chante*
Fidèle Pipeau, on a vécu bien des aventures...
Sache que... *crac*
Jean Valjean !
Je t'aurai !
Tu ne sauveras pas Cosette !
On veut travailler dans la restauration ?
Avant de prendre ton service, tu peux me rendre un petit service ?
Fais voir ton p'tit moineau ma chérie... Ooh... Hhmm
Jean Valjean !
Tu ne sauveras pas Cosette !
Goûte d'abord à la lame de mon épée !
On va jeter de la crotte sur Cosette !
*Cosette chante Fort boyard*
*Cosette chante Fort Boyard*
Les Misérables
Laissez-la, reculez !
Petite Cosette, ils t'ont fait du mal ?
Non, non, c'est bon je me débrouille
Comment ça, ils t'ont fait du mal, petite Cosette ?
Oh, ils t'ont touché la zézette, Cosette...
Montre-moi ta zézette, montre-moi ta zézette, Cosette
Montre-moi ta zézette, Cosette
Cosette, oh...
Stop, stop, STOOP !!
Je peux pas... Oh, casse-toi
Tirez-vous tous !
Avec vos émissions de merde !
Cassez-vous, casse-toi ! Casse-toi !
Euh...On fait une pause ?
Oh, Gavroche !
Petit Gavroche !
Oh, viens nous aider Gavroche !
Oui c'est toi ! Oui, viens !
Prends ton bonnet phrygien et viens défendre la Franc...
*en pleurant* C'est foutu !